hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here is a right-wing lunatic saying
something completely insane
the former president said last night
you're now headed to political oblivion
you said this fight is just beginning
you've even launched a political
organization already so let's just be
straight about it are you considering
running for president yourself
well what i'm going to do savannah is
spend the next several months completing
my work in congress obviously completing
my work representing the people of
wyoming we have a tremendous amount of
work left to do on the january 6th
committee
and also though i'm going to be making
sure that people all around this country
understand the stakes of what we're
facing understand the extent to which
we've now got
one major political party my party
which has really become a cult of
personality and we've got to get this
party back to a place where we're
embracing the values and the principles
on which it was founded uh and and
talking about you know fundamental uh
issues of civics fundamental issues of
what does it mean to be a constitutional
republican but congresswoman you didn't
answer me yesterday
yeah i know donald trump i will be doing
whatever it takes to keep donald trump
out of the oval office well i know you
didn't say yes or no and that's fine if
you're thinking about it but are you
thinking about it are you thinking about
running for president
it uh that's a decision that i'm going
to make in the in the coming months
savannah i'm not going to make any
announcements here this morning but but
it is something that i i'm thinking
about and i'll make a decision in the
coming months